[Musique]
colmar en alsace
ici chaque année en décembre les
habitants se livre à un drôle de rituels
décorer leur maison de haut en bas comme
s'il s'agissait de sapins on va chercher
les ché et si les colmariens se donne
autant de mal pour parer leurs maisons
de mille feux
c'est qu'ils sont 80 à concourir pour le
titre honorifique de plus belle maison
de noël
parmi eux deux favoris jérôme 23 ans et
lucien 64 ans le tenant du titre et il
est bien décidé à le garder laquelle
j'ai envie de gagner qui sait qu'ils
jouent
quant au parquet c'est pas un concours
il a toujours envie gagner son principal
rival
jérôme nom n'est plus non plus à sa
première victoire ça fait des années
2000 on a intégré de serre avec un père
noël et un traîneau dans le jardin cette
année ils voudraient bien remporter à
nouveau le titre honorifique de plus
belle maison de noël et pour séduire le
jury
il a eu une idée un peu folle
transformer son jardin en véritable
forêt enchantée on veut que ça a l'air
d'une forêt et donc après qu'on agrément
de guirlandes de noël tout simplement
est con mais par la suite une biche et
des animaux de la forêt vraiment pour
s'approcher au plus près de la réalité
en fait jérôme travaille sur sa
décoration depuis plus d'un mois
mais pour l'instant à part les sapins
tout reste à installer avant le passage
du jury
le soir même pour noter chaque maison un
jury composé de quinze conseillers
municipaux
jérôme n'a que quelques heures avant de
les voir débarquer dans son jardin mais
pour l'instant il est confiant tout
faire pour y arriver
c'est mon but c'est d'arriver au sur le
podium et d'être là pour la première
place
jérôme est sûr de lui mais à l'autre
bout de la ville son principal
concurrent a pris de l'avancé
lucien est le tenant du titre avec sa
maison alsacienne typique
il a remporté le concours haut la main
l'année dernière il faut dire qu'il
avait mis le paquet cette année pour
tenter de conserver son titre
honorifique
lucien a appelé du renfort à tâter la
donne à papy gustaf
voilà qui la met là bas ses petits
enfants
lucile et thomas ont bien l'intention de
tout faire pour aider leur grand-père a
remporté le concours
[Musique]
et pour gagner comme lucien n'a pas de
jardin il mise tout sur sa façade
d'époque notre décorateur fouilles
accroche tout ce qui lui passe par la
tête
guirlandes ruban paquets cadeaux lumière
en tout genre pour lucien il n'y en a
jamais assez
mais la pièce maîtresse de sa décoration
se trouvent encore à l'intérieur
[Musique]
ne vous fiez pas aux apparences ce n'est
pas une simple maison en carton mais la
reproduction exacte de sa demeure
alsacienne
lucien il travaille sans relâche depuis
15 jours il a tout pensé dans les
moindres détails et ça c'est ma famille
là derrière la fenêtre la tête j'ai mis
là qui arrive à porter il ne lui reste
plus qu'à l'accroché pour mettre un
point final à sa décoration chez jérôme
la forêt enchantée avance à petit pas
car il fabrique lui même ses décorations
inserts et une biche confectionné par
ses soins ont déjà pris place entre les
sapins mais pour jérôme le tableau n'est
pas complet je pose mon fond son
penchant bois on pourra après le
découper donc là c'est tout simplement
le concours un fonds qui s'illuminera à
la nuit tombée ce sera la dernière pièce
de sa forêt enchantée et s'il se lance
lui même dans la fabrication c'est parce
qu'il a une botte secrète
ce tout jeune homme est électricien un
atout qu'il compte bien utiliser pour
proposer une décoration originale et
surtout lumineuse résultats montrent
plus que la découpe et l'installation
des lampes en moins d'une heure
il a réalisé son enfant et il n'est pas
peu fier ça y est maman maman y avoir y
avoir une fois final qu'est ce t'en
penses je pense que ça va bien ça va
bien amélioré notre forêt ça va bien le
mettre en valeur avec nos petites
lumières et aux jolies
au centre ville lucien a complètement
terminée mais au moment d'admirer son
oeuvre il n'est pas totalement satisfait
il est persuadé que sa façade n'est pas
assez des corps est alors à une heure du
passage du jury
il décide de foncer au marché de noël en
quête de nouveaux accessoires pour
mettre encore à la décoration de 0 voilà
merci bien
bonne soirée au plaisir et joyeux noël
aussi à vous oui encore quoi encore quoi
les brillants en tout lucien dépenses
une vingtaine d'euros une somme qu'il
doit ajouter à son budget de départ
d'environ 100 euros
l'addition commence à chiffrer mais
impossible de l'arrêter on dirait que la
fièvre de noël l'a définitivement
terrassé
mais pendant que lucien flambeau marché
de noël jérôme son principal rival ne
perd pas le nord
il profite de l'absence de son
concurrent pour jeter un oeil à sa
maison et la mauvaise surprise ouah ouah
alors là
d'aller vraiment magnifique là elle est
vraiment joli toi qui l'a vraiment bien
mises en valeur et que ça sera vraiment
un concurrent terex jérôme est
impressionné par le travail de lucien
s'il veut rivaliser plus une minute à
perdre
il doit rentrer pour apporter la
dernière touche à sa forêt enchantée la
conclusion
génial je suis vraiment très très fier
de ce qui se passe et due forme qui va
manquer car outre la touche finale à mon
amour d'accord pour sa décoration jérôme
a dépensé près de 300 euros et
uniquement pour la gloire mais en voyant
le résultat
il reprend du poil de la bête au centre
ville c'est la maison de lucien qui créé
l'attraction est particulièrement cette
vitrine
le plus vieux quartiers de la ville
reproduit en miniature
les passants sont bluffés mais c'est le
jury qu'il va falloir séduire de retour
du marché de noël
lucien élu s'il s'empresse d'accrocher
les nouvelles décorations
la maison est enfin terminée il n'y a
plus qu'à attendre le jury toute la
famille est là pour soutenir un lucien
particulièrement angoissée
[Musique]
les stress 20 heures pour le jury c'est
l'heure d'entrer en scène
les conseillers municipaux reconverti en
jurés prennent leur rôle très au sérieux
ils ont mis au point un système de
notation très précis de l'ensemble de la
décoration
l'harmonie des couleurs aussi il faut
que la décoration soit répartie
uniformément sur l'ensemble de la maison
et a pris à la qualité de l'école et à
l'originalité aussi du décor la maison
de jérôme répondra-t-elle aux attentes
du jury c'est bien jolie décoration elle
est sobre et les ya pas trop de couleurs
17 et demi c'est une bonne note mais
tout le monde n'a pas l'air de cet avis
ce jury a beau être déguisé en père noël
il ne fait pas de cadeau le faut je
trouve à un petit peu comme un petit peu
trop faible trop simple et
le fonds de jérôme n'a pas fait
l'unanimité mais sa maison est l'une des
premières jugées alors tout reste
possible
durant la soirée les jurés inspecteront
les 80 installations 22 heures pour
l'instant jérôme est toujours en tête
le jury arrive maintenant devant la
maison de lucien voilà nous y arrivons
devant une très très belle maison j'en
extase chaque année il fait d'autres
d'autres créations c'est vraiment un
artiste je pense qu'il a des petites
scènes cachées dans le don est que
100 volontaires de noël donc
il accroche ses acrobaties comme ça l'a
mis discrètement etc
moi je mets
c'est presque la partition les autres
jurés seront ils aussi enthousiaste
suspense après avoir inspecté les 80
maisons
le jury rentrer à l'hôtel de ville pour
délibérer en principe les résultats
doivent rester secrets pendant un an
mais pour 100% mag le maire a accepté de
déroger à la règle en exclusivité le
gagnant et lucien je l'espérais j'ai
fait ça avec le coeur et je pense quand
même que c'est à prix qui a mérité avec
19 de moyenne sa maison alsacienne ultra
décor et l'emportent encore une fois
quant à jérôme et sa forêt enchantée il
arrive en seconde position avec 17 sur
20 alors bravo à tous les deux et une
chose est sûre jérôme n'a pas dit son
dernier mot
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour la
revanche du fonds illuminé